what's the difference between a
professional level script and one that's
written by an amateur professional level
script can I would say compete in the
professional marketplace where someone
could receive a screenplay and read it
and not go hmm
this has too many problems that this
person probably isn't they're not
writing in a professional level
meaning that somebody would say oh my
gosh this we could make this you know
that it's not plagued with the problems
I think we spoke about before about you
know the first time over writing the
script and and you know the structure
doesn't really work and I don't it's
confusing and it's not fulfill either
the ending doesn't wrap it up you know
things if you were to read that and and
also as we mentioned before a format to
you know you look at the script and if
it's all over the place where it's kind
of clunky and weird and like I've never
what is it's gonna be it's not
professionally written professionally
written how soon into reading a
screenplay do you know that it's bad
well it's uh it's usually in the
beginning but many times you're fooled
because the beginning is easy to set up
so you're like oh this is great and then
longer it goes on it runs out of steam
and then it just really is like okay or
that it's it's too long it's like too
many pages and there's a whole nother
story in half there there that shows
that it needs to be we have a lot of
editing you know for it and if it was a
first draft it's a script and a half
almost you know script in a third let's
say which is overriding so so then a
reader will know fairly quickly a reader
will probably know in the first page or
two if if it's the format give away or
it's just the style give away where it's
you know what I mean you can tell I mean
people all the time post one page on the
internet you know they put up a page of
their script and you can see it and go
okay you know you can it's a giveaway
it's clear giveaway or you can see
another page and go wow you know it's
it's so clear like you're seeing what
they meant to you know like you're
seeing what they're writing not it bump
in I was that who got out the car and
you know it oh oh you know and that goes
back to you know in a way it goes back
to format and how you know what you're
gonna put in and what you're not based
upon the story what do you think about
99% of screenplays being rejected after
the first page um I don't know there we
well I I think they would be read
they're not thrown in the garbage after
page one I think a script is given a
chance I mean I would hope you know from
a reader and then it's the overall
feeling of it but like we were
discussing before if there's too many
bumps and you know the famous thing is
oh this bumps for me you know it's like
it bumps okay it means yeah I mean I
know what they mean but it's probably
like boom you know it sort of bumped in
a not a good way where they he was
confusing or the story was like why did
it go that way and I didn't understand
it was this and that and a lot of times
sadly it's because of skimming you know
where someone just literally you know I
read one time that some people just read
the dialogue or some producer just reads
dialogue he doesn't read the directions
just reads the dialogue you know I don't
know what you know that's not really
reading the script but I think as we
were discussing before you can tell in
the first few pages if it's going to be
one of those scripts or if it's going to
be like wow this is a page-turner I can
already see that you know it's hard to
hide that if you're not writing at a
particular level I mean so that'll be a
dead giveaway which is not good so you
think though people give it more than
just a scene oh sure oh you do
you know the old adage like well it
doesn't happen within the first 10 pages
he used to be the first 20 but now it's
shrunken down if it doesn't happen you
know if I'm reading and it doesn't
happen for me I you know you sort of
have to know what we're getting into but
again these aren't rules not coming from
me I'm just saying somehow that some
movies like you know European films take
longer to happen and you know I'm
talking about Hollywood if you want to
work in that system you know it better
happen the readers got to go ten pages I
still don't know what's happening you
got to get an idea like oh we see this
and that you know me that's what they're
talking about is it happening you know
and don't worry through the script no
but if you if you're plagued with typos
three or four page it means you don't
care enough to proofread your script and
you don't care about enough for the
person who's reading it's time so right
away there's a disrespect there like
well I just got a I just wanted to blow
through it because you know my idea is
so good I don't have to proofread
describe okay you know I mean these are
these are attitudes that won't serve you
well
in the long run
you